la femme est dans un chambre à l'étagé
en train de se préparer quand elle
entend un grand fracas dans l'escalier
chiffres il s'attaquait ce qui se passe
oui oui c'est rien c'est mon manteau qui
est tombée d'un manteau mais pourquoi at
il fait un tel vacarme haut parce que
j'étais dedans
l'homme qui s'assimile à son manteau qui
se confond à son manteau c'est vous
c'est moi
quand nous ne faisons pas la différence
entre qui nous sommes et nos
comportements nos comportements ne sont
que des manteaux que nous avons enfilé
souvent dès la plus tendre enfance pour
ressembler à nos parents pour nous
fondre dans notre milieu d'appartenance
ou dans le milieu auquel nous voulons
appartenir
parfois ce sont des cottes de mailles
voir des armures dans lesquelles nous
glissons pour nous protéger du monde
et si nous nous confondons savez que
c'est parce que nous réagissons le plus
souvent de manière mécanique comme
branché au pilote automatique et parce
que nos réactions sont justement
largement réflexe face aux autres et aux
événements eh bien ce sont souvent ces
autres et ces événements que nous jouons
responsables de notre humeur et de nos
comportements
pourtant les événements sont neutres
pour qui veut bien les observer avec du
recul d'ailleurs tout le monde ne réagit
pas de la même façon
quant aux autres ils se préoccupent le
plus souvent bien moins de nous que de
tirer leur propre épingle du jeu de la
vie alors comment se fait-il que nous
prenions les choses tellement
personnellement pourquoi des marrons
nous au quart de tour systématiquement
dans certaines situations ou face à
telle personne douée semble-t-il pour
nous agresser
la réponse est dans la question
nous réagissons sous le coup de nos
émotions émotions motion en anglais
mouvement ce sont les émotions qui nous
met en mouvement
or ce que nous ressentons est intimement
liée à notre modèle du monde c'est à
dire à la façon dont nous voyons les
choses on nous voyons les autres et dont
nous nous voyons nous mène avez vous
déjà entendu parler
d'alfred korzybski certains d'entre vous
probablement alfred korzybski était un
officier de l'armée russe pendant la
première guerre mondiale qui a établi un
jour un plan de bataille sur la base des
cartes d'état-major qu'il avait à sa
disposition et sur lesquels ne figurait
pas un fossé profond dans lequel l'armée
prussienne avait engueulé scénith
railleuse est donc enfin alfred
korzybski lança ses troupes à l'assaut
il lit son bataillon tout entier se
faire décimer par les mitrailleuses
prussienne caché dans le fameux faux
c'est bien plus tard après la guerre
devenu père de la sémantique général il
s'inspira de cette triste expérience
pour déclarer la carte n'est pas le
territoire
illustrant ainsi que notre perception de
la réalité n'est pas la réalité il n'ya
pas une seule et unique réalité partagée
par tous est-ce que vous et moi ici dans
cette salle à cet instant nous ne
partageons pas une seule et même réalité
l'explication tient dans la coexistence
de deux impossibilités premièrement il
nous est impossible de percevoir tout ce
qui nous entoure
ne serait ce que parce que nous ne
pouvons en avoir connaissance qu'à
travers nos sens qu'ils sont limités
voire même parfois trompeurs
deuxièmement il nous est tout aussi
impossible de ne pas donner de sens à ce
que nous percevons or cette attribution
de sens nous et personnel c'est une
interprétation comme nous avons chacun
notre propre histoire
notre propre expérience de la réalité
nous en avons chacun notre propre
interprétation
alors j'ai revenir sur ces deux points
si vous le voulez bien je vous
apprendrai rien en vous disant que les
êtres humains que nous sommes nous
percevons les informations notre
environnement à travers nos cinq sens la
vue l'ouïe l'odorat le goût le toucher
c'est le filtre neurologique qui restera
notre réalité parce que nos sens sont
limitées
on sait bien en effet par exemple que si
nous partageons un même environnement
avec une mouche ou avec un chien la
mouche avec ses yeux à facettes à une
vision à 360° que nous n'avons pas et
que le chien persuadé son que nous
n'entendons pas manifeste
demant notre carte n'est pas la carte de
la mouche ni la carte du chien il n'est
certainement pas exhaustive
certainement pas représentatif de toute
la réalité à l'instant qu il n'y a pas
que les animaux qui voit les choses
autrement que nous il suffit de voyager
pour se rendre compte que ce qui nous
semble évident ne l'est pas sous
d'autres cieux pour des personnes qui
partagent pourtant là pour le coup avec
nous un même équipement neurologiques
alors pourquoi est ce que ces personnes
ne voient pas les choses ne voit pas la
vie de la même façon que nous eh bien
parce qu'elles n'ont pas la même culture
la culture propre à une population
donnée modèle sa réalité impact de la
façon dont elle voit les choses est ce
être différents niveaux à commencer par
le niveau du langage qui véhiculent
cette culture parce qu'en effet ce que
la langue des signes
peut être distingué alors que ce qui n'a
pas de nom risque de passer inaperçu
c'est pour ça que les chercheurs s'en
prennent toujours de donner un nom aux
nouvelles espèces planète c'est lui qui
découvre parce que les mots représentent
la réalité il nous la ronde présente et
ce qui n'a pas de nom n'existe
potentiellement pas ainsi certaines
peuplades primitives n'ont pas de mots
pour parler de l'avenir nous leur verbe
notamment ne se conjugue au présent et
au passé
et bien pour ces populations il est
impossible d'envisager le futur de s'y
projeter de l'est de se le représenter
imaginez un petit peu ce que ça
changerait pour nous si nous ne pouvions
pas anticiper prévoir planifier
probablement que nous ne serions pas là
en tout cas ça changerait grandement
notre façon de vivre dans un autre
registre les eskimos ont des dizaines de
qualificatifs pour désigner des sortes
de neige que nous ne distinguons pas
sous nos latitudes
parce que nous n'avons pas les mots pour
le faire donc le langage c'est un
premier niveau du filtre culturel un
autre niveau ce sont les valeurs et les
croyances d'un groupe donné qui est bien
sûr un pacte grandement la façon qu'a ce
groupe de voir les choses et puis à
l'intérieur d'un même groupe
et encore d'autres influences comme la
famille et la religion et les individus
que nous sommes eh bien nous adoptons la
culture les vannes
les croyances en accord avec notre
milieu d'appartenance ou en opposition à
lui si nous refusons nous identifier et
nous y ajoutons notre propre histoire
les expériences que nous avons vécu les
conclusions que nous en avons tiré
souvent d'être plus jeune âge pour
déterminer ce qui est vrai est important
pour nous c'est notre filtre personnel
nous filtrons la réalité en fonction de
nos critères personnels
ainsi par exemple s'il est important
pour vous qu'une personne et de la
culture générale où est le sens de
l'humour pour vous en faire un ami va
peut être pas ou peu regardé son
apparence physique son statut social son
compte en banque
critères qui seront importants pour
d'autres que vous
la juxtaposition de ces filtres filtre
neurologiques litres culturel et filtres
personnel constituent les lunettes à
travers lesquelles nous percevons la
réalité à travers lesquelles nous
sélectionnons généralisons d'histoire
dont les informations de notre
environnement pour nous en faire une
représentation très personnel interne en
accord avec notre modèle du monde il ya
un américain qui s'appelle georges
univers qui a de fait démontré que nous
pouvons avoir conscience de plus de
cette information alors plus ou moins
deux selon les personnes à tout instant
bien sûr il nous en arrive beaucoup plus
par nos sens à tout moment aussi bien
des informations entre environnement
extérieur peut aider au regard des
informations antérieures
notre dialogue inter les informations
notre corps et c'est donc nous devons
sélectionner nous choisissons en
fonction de ce qui nous intéresse en
fonction de ce qui nous semble vrai
important et puis aussi nous
généralisons pour intégrer un maximum
d'informations à l'intérieur de ces sept
blocs dont nous pouvons avoir conscience
et pour cela nous a glosé rond des
éléments d'information qui se
ressemblent en étendant à toute une
catégorie de personnes ou de situation
ce que nous avons vécu dans une ou un
petit nombre de circonstances
c'est ce qui permet l'apprentissage mais
par exemple appris à conduire sur une
voiture vous allez pouvoir tout les
conduire mais c'est aussi
malheureusement la base de nos préjugés
de toutes ces grandes généralités que
nous entendons tous les jeunes sont des
feignants toutes les
sans lui le volant tous les hommes sont
maîtres chaud mais aussi tu ne m'écoutes
jamais c'est toujours la même chose
etc et puis parfois aussi nous dit
stores dont les éléments de la réalité
nous les efforts n'ont pour les plier à
notre modèle du monde comme cet homme
qui se prenait pour un cadavre et or
sont médecins ne savaient plus quoi
faire pour lui démontrer qu'il n'en
n'était pas un bon jour le médecin lui
dit pensez vous que les cadavres scène
non dit l'homme je suis pas fou je viens
avec les cadors online pas alors le
médecin il prend la main pic le bout du
doigt
bien sûr une goutte de sang perle ça
alors je n'aurais jamais cru que les
cadavres pouvaient seigner et bien nous
faisons tous ça à certains moments
inconsciemment nous dit stores dont la
réalité pour la plier à nos croyances
d'ailleurs vous avez sans doute tous
déjà lu de ces conversations votre
interlocuteur vous soutient que j'ai
jamais dit ça et pourtant vous êtes
persuadé de l'avoir entendu parce que
vous êtes convaincu que c'est ce que
l'autre pense ou devrait penser
on voit bien en tout cas que filtrer et
procès s'est maintes fois notre
perception de la réalité non seulement
n'est pas la réalité mais que encore
elle nous en éloigne dans de notre
réalité externe de l'environnement qui
nous entoure mais aussi de notre réalité
personnelle parce que en effet c'est la
façon dont nous percevons et
interprétons les choses qui génère les
émotions qui nous met en mouvement et
qui détermine donc notre attitude dans
la vie il n'y a en effet aucune raison
de ressentir une émotion ou telles
émotions plutôt que telle autre face à
un événement à moins d'avoir donné à
celui ci un sens particulier
illustration on vous fait un compliment
la logique voudrait que vous vous en
sortiez flatter heureux mais si vous
avez la conviction que les gens ne sont
jamais gentil gratuitement eh bien vous
et vous demandez ce que l'autre attend
de vous vous allez gaieté dans ses mots
dans son ton de voix dans les mimiques
de son visage les signes de sa duplicité
vous allez ressentir de la méfiance si
votre croyance elle est plutôt que vous
ne méritez pas le compliment
vous allez peut être le voir comme de la
moquerie interpréter le sourire de votre
interlocuteur comme de l'ironie et vous
allez vous sentir vexé blessés voire en
colère une même situation des réactions
différentes et donc quand on pense que
ce sont les premières qui génère les
seconds ont fait un raccourci qui omet
tout le processus internes souvent
inconscient est en tout cas très
personnelle de perception
l'interprétation et émotion qui est en
réalité à l'oeuvre les quilles et
l'accumulation de valeur de croyance et
en bout de course de comportement pour
faire respecter ses valeurs et ses
croyances tous fruits de notre culture
de notre éducation de notre histoire
personnelle tout ce manteau pour
reprendre mon analogie initiale que nous
avons enfilé souvent dès le plus jeune
âge pour imiter nos parents et nos
modèles
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'un manteau ça
se retire même si vous l'avez adopter
pour une très bonne raison
au départ si aujourd'hui ne vous
convient plus vous pouvez vous en
débarrasser parce que ce n'est pas qui
nous sommes profondément ce n'est que
conditionnement nous ne sommes pas nés
avec toutes ces couches de croyances et
de réaction réflexe il y avait
d'ailleurs une publicité qui passait il
ya quelques mois à la télévision dans
laquelle on demandait à des jeunes
montre moi comment c'est de courir comme
une fille de se battre comme une fille
de jeter comme une fille et on y voyait
d'abord des adolescents qui me met une
fille un peu chaude soucieuse du regard
des autres et puis ensuite on voyait des
filles est de 9 10 ans qui se donnait à
fond dans l'exercice sans complexe sans
retenue parce qu'à cet âge là elles
n'ont pas encore été conditionné à ce
qu'une fille est censé être est censé
pouvoir faire et non pas encore enfilé
le manteau de la peur du regard des 11
elles sont donc naturel
mais son entière elles sont elles-mêmes
qui elles sont profondément est la
deuxième bonne nouvelle c'est que cette
partie naturelle pur entière elle vit
encore en chacun de nous et que donc
nous pouvons nous retrouver nous mêmes
nous pouvons retrouver la cohérence
entre nos comportements et qui nous
sommes en revenons à notre processus
pour cette fois non plus accuser les
faits les situations les événements mais
peut-être remettre en cause la façon
dont nous les avons perçu ou la façon
dont nous les avons interprété ou la
façon dont nous avons cherché à
respecter au faire respecter ce qui est
vrai est important pour nous dans cette
situation dans tous les cas vous l'aurez
compris la solution est à chercher non
pas à l'extérieur dans les faits chez
les autres même si c'est plus est
souvent plus facile mais de chercher la
clé là où elle se trouve vraiment à
l'intérieur de nous quitte à devoir pour
cela explorer nos zones d'ombré il ne
pas faire comme cet homme qui était à la
nuit tombée en train de fouiller du
regard le trottoir sous un réverbère
arrive à un passant qui lui demande s'il
a perdu quelque chose oui j'ai perdu mes
clés à temps l'ami je vais t'aider à les
chercher et les deux hommes se met à
chercher chercher à chercher jusqu'à ce
que finalement le passant de man mais tu
es sûr tu les as perdu ici tes clés un
nom je les ai pas perdu 8,6 les ai
perdus chez moi dans mon jardin
bah tu as perdu dans ton jardin pourquoi
est-ce que tu l'aies cherche ici mais
parce qu'ici mais la lumière
je vous remercie